today it's a sumo suit ping-pong that
look pretty looks I got those done that
before you offered that part no you guys
look hilarious
I will have this wrong it's like a sumo
warrior you both look like warriors and
guys come on out
you can do it yes
[Applause]
whoa is it high inside the suit that's
kind before
imagine how many sweaty people I go been
in that suit
[Music]
it doesn't seem to be affecting up
[Music]
you go the full way behind that smashing
I didn't miss him in a ping-pong match
but I can be innocent
all right what's your tactic just curl
it you crawl in okay see you the other
side
I'm sure why but if Mika looks even
funnier in the dress it's just like a
small around guy
[Music]
Oh
I feel like my weight is doubled
[Applause]
[Music]
come on try you can do it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm not getting up for the second
now I'm stuck again I think my shoelaces
guy is more on the floor than he's
actually like on his feet
I mean he's very much normal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's fine to see the reactions are the
Sigma suit
[Music]
yes
[Music]
what's up a new day
[Music]
sleeping position it's quite comfortable
it's surprising popular don't forget to
here subscribe on watch our previous
episodes there until next time
pika you can come up already makeup
makeup where did it go